après quelques semaines de gloire il est
temps pour les sapins de retirer leurs
tenues de fêtes leur place est désormais
sur les trottoirs durant le mois de
janvier dans les communes de saint
quentin en yvelines ils seront ramassés
pour être recyclés
c'est la société sepur basée à thiverval
grignon qui est chargé de collecter et
de valoriser ces sapins on va les broyer
et puis une fois qu'ils seront broyés on
va pouvoir les valoriser principalement
en biomasse puisque effectivement c'est
quand même très ligne comme matière et
avec cette biomasse on va renvoyer sa
dans des chaudières qui vont permettre
de créer soit de la chaleur soit
d'électricité
les aiguilles des sapins elles seront
broyés elles deviendront ensuite du
compost destinées à fertiliser les sols
une opération écologique à condition de
respecter quelques consignes
il est fait il est spécifique pour le
compostage qui va se dégrader en même
temps que le process de compostage donc
il ne sera pas dit non ce qui est gênant
se sont tous qui est guirlandes boules
de noël où là je ne sais pas faire du
compost avec donc jean toujours tendance
à dire on en irlande les gens alors
cette année entre 100 et 200 tonnes soit
un millier de sapins qui ont fait le
bonheur des saint quentinois connaîtront
une deuxième vie